en belgique donc le match angleterre
allemagne comptant pour l'euro 2000
déchaîne les hooligans des incidents ont
éclaté dès cet après-midi à charleroi où
ce soir doit se dérouler la rencontre
des bagarres entre 5000 supporters
anglais et allemands ont obligé les
forces de l'ordre à intervenir la police
belge s'attend à passer une soirée
mouvementée
le reportage de nos envoyés spéciaux à
charleroi marie-pierre courtellemont et
jean gène muté les anglais se sont
installés à gauche de la place les
allemands ont pris position sur la
droite d'un camp à l'autre des gestes de
provocation
les policiers belges sont au milieu pour
contenir la haine
il faut montrer aux anglais que nous les
allemands nous sommes là mais vous ne
pensez pas que quand vous crier comme ça
cela énerve les anglais et qu'ils ne
sont pas très contents ça m'est
complètement égal que les anglais soit
content ou pas
les allemands doivent savoir que nous
sommes là qu'il y a des milliers de
supporters anglais est si puissant débat
d'idées largement nourris à la bière
alors en début d'après midi
il suffit d'une bagarre entre deux
supporters et toute la place charles ii
devient un vaste champ de bataille
les canons à eau interviennent
immédiatement ils ne suffiront pas à
calmer les esprits
il est bart servent toujours de l'alcool
n'aurait pas fait mieux maintenant
imaginez si je veux maintenant je dirais
peut fermer et je crois qu'ils vont
tourner mon café je peux pas dire
maintenant dégager tous parce qu'il fait
vous prenez une lourde responsabilité en
continuant à servir de l'alcool
aujourd'hui peut-être tiré par contre
assez alors les affrontements se
poursuivent
depuis le début de l'après midi la
police belge a déjà interpellé plus
d'une centaine de supporters des deux
bords et la nuit s'annonce très longue
à charleroi